eight nine ten yep thank you wow cool
nearly everybody dreams of kissing a
celeb and yet celebrities don't even
want to kiss each other it's such a
shame how glamorized the movies can make
these moments when they're usually
awkward at best or downright repulsive
at worst we're taking a look at some of
the worst you know this may be the best
date i've ever been on technically this
isn't a date right
not a date
number one if you stand completely still
maybe they won't be able to see you
sholomera duena and mary mousers
on-screen kisses in cobra kai don't just
look awkward mary finds them to be
awkward because for some strange reason
cholo's not engaging with his hands in
any way i feel like every picture of us
kissing my hands are on your face and
your hands are nowhere near me show
low's response is that he's scared of
her and like the worm from dune yikes
in the best way
in the best way way to reel that insult
back in it was the first time in our
relationship
that paul was genuinely mad at me number
two snot vision paul bettany's runny
nose in wandavision made for an awkward
smooch between him and elizabeth olsen
because of all the layers of prosthetics
and makeup paul had no idea he's just
dropped snot on his co-star elizabeth
made a joke about it and it did not go
over too well she says it's the first
time paul was genuinely mad at her
elizabeth scott
as i think we can all agree to call her
henceforth somebody's a bit embarrassed
number three millie really put the
pressure on finn to admit she was his
first serious kiss millie bobby brown
and finn wolfhard had to kiss in front
of 200 people including their parents
and it was super awkward
watching back the kissing scene he'd
said looks like i was eating her like i
was like ah like that
number four first kisses are daunting
sadie sink hadn't had her first kiss
before either and show showrunner ross
duffer made a joke that she would have
to kiss caleb at some point this led to
sadie freaking right the heck out and
duffer deciding to add a kiss in right
then just because of how goofy she'd
reacted to the idea of it what no no
that's not in the script
that's not happening
either way despite her freakout she felt
comfortable with the scene and said she
wouldn't have gone ahead with it if she
didn't meanwhile her co-kisser was also
feeling just a bit nervous as it was
also his first kiss this is feeling
weird millie had just gotten done
filming her kissing scene with finn
she'd walked out all red then everybody
was saying you're next to sadie and
caleb that's too stressful number five
we're getting a little too specific now
angelica washington's struggle with
kissing her co-star in tall girls 2
mostly came from the director trying to
get the shot just right angelica
clarifying it was the director saying
things like can you move your hand like
that or like how long can you hold her
more i'm like it just takes away from
trying to make it real you know ava
michelle found herself in the same boat
with griffin gluck but just when they
think smooching is over for a while
they're instructed to do it again but
this time
different
prompting her to wonder how many
variations of a kiss can we get
number six
all of us are dying laughing at cho's
reason why they had to film the scene so
many times cho yi hyun had said she felt
bad for her kissing partner because she
had her eyes closed when she was leaning
in for the kiss and so she couldn't find
where his lips were
[Music]
it took 17 takes to get it right our
question is isn't it normal to have your
eyes closed for a kiss what's her excuse
joey was determined to handle her
situation like an adult joey king and
jacob allordy broke up before filming
for kissing booth 2. joey admitted no
one's thinking to themselves that was
easy because it wasn't she also knew
that fans would overanalyze the moments
hoping for some connection between her
character and her real life but joey
wasn't going to let her personal
feelings get in the way of her work
saying elle evan needs her noah flynn
and whatever that means for my personal
life i'll do anything to make sure the
story of my character who i care about
so much is complete number eight she had
a crush on tom felton but all she got to
do with him was punch him in the nose
meanwhile she did have to kiss both
daniel radcliffe and rupert grint at
different points the kissing scene with
daniel being particularly strange given
it was like being naked with your
sibling not fun daniel admitted as much
saying it was kinda weird it is a bit
like kissing your sister dan thought it
was going to be a kind of a slow sensual
thing and emma really went for it rupert
wound up kicked out of the room while
they were filming the scene because he
kept laughing number nine schmidt in any
other context would be incredibly
annoying jake johnson who plays nick was
against max greenfield kissing him at
first for good reason it was unscripted
and caught him by surprise matt's
improvise kissed me a bunch in the show
yeah but it wasn't until the seventh
time that one of those improvised kisses
made it into an episode i have been
kissed the most by max in two seasons
than any girl i've ever dated
at first jake's reactions were super
aggressive when he'd push max's face
away or hit him but by the end he'd
accepted that it was part of the show
and it worked number 10 imagine having
somebody coaching you from the sidelines
on your intimate moments it would be
just a bit awkward jacob allordy
struggled with all of his intimate
scenes in season one not just kissing
scenes because he couldn't quite get
used to the structure of having an
intimacy coordinator around he found it
restricting and didn't leave room for
spontaneity which is kind of the point
of the job but he learned that during
season 2 and realized he was super
grateful for the coordinator number 11.
j-law was rightfully nervous celebs
can't help but fall for their co-stars
jennifer lawrence felt incredibly
awkward kissing chris pratt because
she'd never kissed a married man before
and so she just felt icky about the
whole thing number 12 we guess there are
some things spider-man can't do what has
turned into a fantasy fairy tale type of
kiss that other shows have tried to copy
like the oc was genuinely a nightmare to
shoot for toby maguire because he was
dangling upside down in the rain water
was running up his nose and then when
kirsten pulled his mask down it
completely covered his nose and he
couldn't breathe 13. if two people make
out in the forest and no one's around to
see it did it really happen armie hammer
and timote chalamet were invited by the
director outside to rehearse a scene
it's their first rehearsal and the
director says let's flip to scene 72 and
they do and it's a kissing scene and it
says elio and oliver kiss in the grass
so they get on the ground and start
making out and the director goes no no
no no
you're not feeling it you need to feel
it and so they do it again and they're
going on for a long while and nobody's
stopping them and we look up and luca is
totally gone he just left us there in
the grass number fourteen k stew was not
team jacob kristen stewart found her
kissing scene with taylor lautner to be
awkward mostly because it felt out of
character for her saying that kissing
jacob was so against everything that
bella's always been number 15. for one
of tv's cutest couples this one actually
comes as a surprise jason siegel and
alison hannigan played marshall and lily
on how i met your mother and alison
couldn't stand kissing jason because he
always smelled like cigarettes number
16. why do people think kissing in the
rain is so romantic ian summerhalder and
nina dobrev had to kiss in the rain when
it was below 30 degrees that's -1 for
the celsius users it was so cold that
the muscles in ian somerhalder's jaw
froze and he couldn't speak the fans
were hoping for more steamy rain kisses
but dobrev absolutely refused saying you
write another rain kiss and i quit
number 17 okay this one actually warms
our hearts hilary duff had a crush on
her co-star in a cinderella story chad
michael murray honestly who didn't so
naturally she felt super nervous about
their kissing scenes at first but they
became good friends and it got easier as
they filmed number 18 masks for
pattinsons robert pattinson was filled
with snot during his smooch with reese
witherspoon he admitted he was wiping
his nose on her wig while he makes it
sound intentional we're hoping it was
accidental because you i think kind of
might be the reaction number 19 incest
isn't what made it awkward kit
harrington and amelia clark definitely
friend zoned each other in game of
thrones for a good reason i like looking
at it and going oh god i'm sorry kit was
dating his then girlfriend now wife rose
leslie kit saying of amelia if you've
known someone for six years and they're
best friends with your girlfriend and
your best friends with them there is
something unnatural and strange about
doing a love scene number 20. jennifer
lawrence did not leave her co-star
hungry for more jayla was kind of a jerk
when it came to kissing liam hemsworth
she'd eat all kinds of gross things
leading up to a kiss
liam admitted right before the scene
she'd be like yeah i ate tuna or i had
garlic and i didn't brush my teeth and
i'd be like fantastic i can't wait to
get in there and taste it rude
it sounds like the inclusion of intimacy
coordinators is a step in the right
direction perhaps one day it won't even
be worth spilling the beans on staged
kisses because they'll be just as normal
as fight choreography do you have a
celeb crush who you would kiss even if
their breath tasted like tuna